how are you doing sir
i'm doing well stephen how are you i'm
doing excellent um
i like the zoom backdrop that you have
today uh yeah we love the boys
oh it's over here oh no it's over there
opposite side there we go
yes exactly um so i have to start with
the most important thing which is
congratulations on your emmy nominations
thank you so much you know i i was so
blindsided and shocked and
always forget when that's going to be
announced so it was um like christmas
a complete surprise and what a great
honoring for two fantastic shows
i'm in such great company we have a
wonderful amount of
nominations for the mandalorian as well
as better call saul
and so i'm really a tribute to both
casts and
um all of the directors producers
writers
and networks that um allowed me to be a
part of both of those shows
listen i i love the boys i think it was
one of my favorite series of last year
i think what eric kripke has done with
the material is incredible
when you signed on how much did eric
tell you about
the full arc of what he was envisioning
for what you'd be doing
well he told me very little not often
what happens with writers
uh eric and i have in his history from
working together on revolution
uh prior to this i ran into him in the
studio doing another show
up in canada and chatted with him in the
hallway he started scratching his head
and look at me a certain way that i
recognized
and that way and i said to him without
him saying a word
eric i know what you're thinking and i
busted out laughing and he said well if
you know what i'm thinking will you do
it i said eric i love you i'll do
anything see you bye call my people
you know so that was it and then he
you know i i had an idea talking with
him on the phone
what kind of person he wanted me to play
but i really
thought that i would be coming in and
out of the show for an episode or two
here or there
um but i like the idea that that that
could be the case because
um when you don't see a character often
and you see him and he makes an
impression
and he has weight and he has grace and
aplomb
then you're interested in that character
and you want to see him more
and so i knew very very little as far as
i was concerned
madeline was at the reigns i was her
boss you meet me
i am the guy that might slide in and out
and be possibly in control of the
company
and then things started to shift in
regard to
conversations that eric would have for
me and he said look you know
i just love what you're doing and i want
to expand things so
i had no clue that it would become what
it is
until it piqued my interest as well see
i'm in agreement with you
you know i started watch some of these
episodes and sort of draw the
correlation between what's going on on
our show
and the kind of um camp
nature of things which i first thought
when i would read it on the page a
little campy
um a little you know it feels a little
bit like
uh um disney world but then the writing
reflects the essence of what's really
important
and going on behind these human beings
who happen to be
have these powers and i thought oh okay
and then i started to put together the
political social economical
economic ideas behind vaught
and what edgar's really trying to do and
i thought oh there's room for me here
there's room to be able to really play
and that's what i love about qrikby and
that's what i love about the boys it's a
playful show but yet it's rooted in such
um very realistic uh
uh a realistic world like we can make
these correlations everything is
entertainment now
like we're in an amusement park you know
we're at disney world you know and these
characters
as opposed to being stuffed animals and
and walking around and entertaining your
kids
are powerful dangers and have a reality
to them
that is human and that's where stan
comes in he understands that
he understands how to be able to speak
to each one of his each and every one of
his superheroes
to allow them to feel empowered that
they could have human feeling
they're a little out of control because
they're just finding out
what compound v really does in their
bloodstream
sure in uh i've seen the first three
episodes of season two
and you have a great scene or two with
homelander
um and anthony plays him so diabolically
he's
so good in the role obviously you are
fantastic in the role
what is it like doing some of those
scenes with him when you're standing
opposite homelander because it's like
it's just very well done well you know i
i
have utmost respect for anthony and it
wasn't until after i
shot the first this first season of the
boys that i went back and watched a show
that that i've been wanting to watch for
a long time called banshee
a very different characterization on
anthony's part this particular show
anthony it's complicated
uh and i start to really see this
man-child
and we have man children in our
government
in america and and the the fragile
nature
of his psyche and for me
and and so and i have to get around um
because i played characters in capes
before
this guy he's walking around looking
like he does
so i like to in my brain
taunt anthony for having to wear that
silly jumpsuit that allows him to feel
powerful
he's certainly powerful without it i
love
the scenes that we have together because
i'm able to be
in a way some somewhat fatherly
sometimes
teacherly uh but very very
calm at his bluster even though he's so
very dangerous
why because i know what he really wants
is to be loved he wants acceptance of
course he wants power
who doesn't but he doesn't have that so
i have to
allow him to know power is not his
stardom could be don't you have a
premiere to go to go
and play you know what you're doing is
playing what i'm doing is trying to run
a company
um i have to switch subjects to
something else you're on because
obviously i love the mandalorian
um you've gotten to do a lot of cool
[ __ ] with your job uh with what all the
roles you've done
is it any better is the peak
training with a lightsaber does it get
better than that
oh you know it doesn't you know when
you're
first you i have to get beyond the
excitement of being in such an iconic
um uh piece of material like iconic star
wars is iconic
and would i have liked to have been in a
star wars movie as opposed to the
mandalorian television show
um i think my choices are significantly
i think i've made this a significantly
correct choice
because what drew me to star wars was
the
the mythological aspect
of storytelling the v and john favreau
in his
um great visionary way has educated
himself
and partnered with david filoni so that
mythology that was so connected to
what george lucas loved he was a friend
of joseph campbell
who wrote the mythological books about
the heroes
that i have read that allow people to be
empowered
so for me it was an empowering moment
firstly to get beyond being a part of
the franchise and then to realize
i was going to wield a lightsaber this
is iconic
this is uh um larger than life
how do i then create a character in maf
gideon that people
um fear but also will follow
and will listen to and how do i
keep the secrets secret until they
uh deserve uh to be known so
i i've been head over heels at at being
involved in that particular show
do you get to get in on a lot of the
stunts in season two what what is it
like doing stuff like that
you know yes we have a and i don't want
to to allow you to have any spoilers but
i
did all of my stunt work on my own
without a lot of rehearsal even though
it's a
fairly big budget technological piece
with the volume and all the things that
are going on
sometimes that leaves less time to pay
more attention to
and the stunt work by the way has been
honored with an ambient nomination as
well
to do that so having a lightsaber uh i
have a couple of different ones
because of the technology that's
involved they sometimes
put the saber in and i have a handle
only but in working with that handle
i have to remember that there's you know
four
and a half five feet more of that saber
so it's the way you handle it so
um i had to practice and sometimes i
have a full saber that lights up
um and i hope i'm not giving too much
away in regard to the technology of it
so yes i had to practice my moves and
it's all in the wrist
to to to allow us to see if that saber
is not there
you you know you you want to keep your
wrist a certain way so it was
it was a bit complicated uh and i have
to laugh because uh
i i don't hold back and so
in some of our stunt work in this season
you are to see very soon
uh you know i i i think i went through
you know i remember the props guy coming
to me and said um
okay so this is our last lightsaber you
know because you got to pull your hits
you don't want to destroy the technology
but you want it to look real isn't that
ultimately what we want
so it was tricky and and wonderful and i
had to be very attentive
um i have to stop there i just want to
say how much i loved already what i've
seen of season two of the boys
obviously a huge fan of your work can't
wait to see everything else have a
fantastic day
thank you so much